[Music]
hello i'm dr michio kaku professor of
theoretical physics
and i'd like to talk about the theory of
everything but from a different point of
view today i want to talk about the
historic as well as the personal
implications of a theory of everything
but first of all let me be honest i'm
coming from a certain point of view of
course
i've been working on string theory since
1968
however i'll try to give you a balanced
historic view of this whole question
first of all i first heard about a
theory of everything when i was eight
years old
something happened which changed my life
completely
it was in all the newspapers all the
newspapers announced that a great
scientist had just died but they put a
picture this picture of the evening news
and the commentators said that the
greatest scientist of our time could not
finish this book
on his desk was a book that could not be
finished by the greatest scientist of
our time
well
i was fascinated by the story
who was this man why couldn't he finish
this book i mean it's a homework problem
right why couldn't he ask his mother why
couldn't he go to the library well
that's what i did
i decided that i wanted to go to the
library
to find out what is this theory that
this man could not finish
that is what is the theory of everything
well in the library they told me that
his name was albert einstein
and it was to be the theory of
everything that is an equation perhaps
no more than one inch long that would
allow us to quote read the mind
of god
well
i was fascinated by the story and i said
to myself i i want to be part of this
dream
i want to be part of this effort to
complete this dream
of a theory that would unify all the
forces of the universe
so in my latest book which is a new york
times bestseller the god equation
i talk about this historic quest this
historic quest
going all the way back in the annals of
time
you see all of us
have wondered
what does it all mean
when we look at the night sky
and we see the billions of stars in the
universe
we say to ourselves
what what message could the universe be
telling me what does it all mean why
where is the farthest star where is the
end of space and time
these are the questions that you ask
yourself on a simple night simply
looking at the night sky
well it was aristotle who tried to put
some of these thoughts down on paper and
ink
and he said that the universe is
composed of four things
there was a unified theory of everything
there was air
water fire earth
from these four substances you could
derive everything else
well
also we had democritus
democritus believed in something called
atoms a means cannot
means cut
atom literally means that which cannot
be cut
but then pythagoras the famous
mathematician of the pythagorean theorem
came out and said no no no no it's not
air water and fire it's not adam's
it's
music
you see one day he looked at a liar
string
and he plucked it
and he realized that the notes on a liar
string come in discreet quantities
and then he went to a blacksmith
and the blacksmith if you hit a bar of
iron the longer the iron the lower the
note
so he said aha
that explains the diversity
the splendorous diversity of matter in
the universe
music
is nothing but different vibrations on a
liar string that's
what the universe is all about
well of course the roman empire fell
apart around 400 a.d so or so
and
all these philosophical discussions came
to a rest
however that didn't stop people from
speculating about these things
the ptolemaic system thought that the
universe could be explained in epicycles
cycles within cycles within cycles
that's what drives the universe
copernicus thought no no no the earth is
not the center of the solar system it is
the sun
but all these academic debates going all
the way back to galileo were finally
resolved with the work of isaac newton
he was walking on his country estate one
day and saw an apple fall
and then he asked the question for the
ages
if an apple falls to the earth
does the moon also fall
well the answer is yes the moon falls
like an apple but it spins around the
earth so in other words newton came up
not with just the theory of gravity he
came with a unified theory a theory that
unified the laws of the heaven
with the laws of the earth even though
the church
said that the heavens obeyed celestial
laws and were perfect while earthlings
live with mortal sin
and corruption
newton said no there's a unified theory
a universal theory of gravity well that
held for the next 200 years with the
next advance coming with james clerk
maxwell
he wrote down the laws of electricity e
here
and magnetism or b shown here
and then he noticed something he noticed
that if e vibrates it turns into
magnetism b
but if magnetism vibrates it turns back
into e
and then he asks himself the question
for the ages
if e turns into b turns back into e
then what is the speed of that
transition that wave that is created
he calculated it and he had the shock
of his life
he found that the speed
of vibrating electromagnetic fields
is a speed of light
in other words this is
a theory of light but it's a unified
theory e and b
are symmetrical in these equations
if you turn a e into b and b into e it's
hardly possible to tell them apart
so in other words he created a unified
theory
just the same way that newton created a
theory that unified the heavens and the
earth
well but we still have the problem
raised all the way back by democritus
why are there so many
different kinds of substances
well mendeleev of course
took a giant step forward by putting all
the basic elements into a chart
but then the question is where did the
chart come from
finally we had a picture of the inside
of the atom
ernest rutherford shown here took a
piece of radium
which glowed with the new kind of force
worked out by madame kiri the nuclear
force
well the nuclear force seemed to be
beyond the work of newton beyond the
work of maxwell
so he put radium in a lead box shown
here on the left
and the beam that came out he shot
through a piece of gold
and then these particles these alpha
particles scattered in all directions in
other words there was a hard ball
a hard ball at the center
of the atom in other words we now had a
picture of the atom itself
electrons electrons moving around a very
dense core made out of protons and
neutrons
so by the 1930s
scientists began to say aha
we have now a theory of everything
gravity can be explained by newton
light can be explained by maxwell's
equations
and the atom can be explained by protons
neutrons and electrons it was so simple
so people began to say this is it
physics is coming to a close we now have
a theory of everything we see around us
well not so fast
you see after world war ii
people began to say well are there
particles beyond the neutrons and the
protons that we missed
so what they did was they started to
build atom smashers like the cyclotron
shown here
gigantic machines which would whirl
particles around in a circle and then
smash them giving us insight into what
is
inside a proton what is inside a neutron
are there more particles that we missed
well
yes
when scientists begin to piece apart the
proton
they found much to their dismay
that there were scores of particles
higher excitations of the proton
this was a mess
it was thought to be simple neutrons
protons and electrons that's it that
makes up the universe nope
inside the proton there are quarks
three quarks that make up the proton a
quark and an antiquark make up what is
called the meson
and soon we had
a zoo
of zoo of subatomic particles so did the
zoo ever end
well of course
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you